je suis Emmanuel de tarot je travaille
chez Thalès et mes activités concernent
deux grands sujets la cybersécurité et
de les infrastructures numériques dont
les dans les réseaux en particulier
Thalès vend des systèmes et des systèmes
critiques en général du système où les
vies humaines peuvent être en jeu et
donc le niveau de sécurité c'est système
et de façon indispensable forcément
élevé on ne peut pas développer la
technologie pour faire de la vie unique
dans un avion avec la sûreté des
commandes de vol sans se poser la
question de la cybersécurité on peut pas
se poser la question depuis l'otage du
système industriel critique dans le
domaine du nucléaire par exemple sans se
poser la question de la cybersécurité et
il y a une partie pure de cybersécurité
ou la cybersécurité se vend sous forme
de produits ou de services Élancourt
étant de éteindre nos socles des
endroits où notaire la cybersécurité
tous les gens peuvent externaliser ou
profiter des compétences d'un acteur qui
est qui suit au jour le jour les menaces
et les solutions de cyber sécurité et
donc une partie de ces de ces opérations
la plus grosse partie historique est à
Élancourt